المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في
الجيش الاوكراني تحدثت عن ان مجموعه السفن
العسكريه الروسيه في البحر الاسود تقدر
بنحو 15 سفينه تنتشر بشكل متفرق وان
القوات الروسيه شكلت ما وصفته اوكرانيا
بمنطقه تفتيش للسفن قرب مضيق كوتش هذه
التطورات تاتي ضمن سياق عسكري روسيا
استهدفت في الاسابيع الاخيره اهم موانئ
اوكرانيا على البحر الاسود من اودي
الساستراتيجي واستهدفت ايضا الموانئ
البديله على نهر الدانوب من اريني وميناء
اسماعيل اوكرانيا بدورها نفذت هجمات على
ميناء نوفروسيسك الذي يعد اكبر موانئ
روسيا حيث استهدفت سفينه انزال واختلفت
الروايات عن حجم الضرر التي لحق بها كما
حددت اوكرانيا عددا من الموانئ الروسيه
وقالت انها س اهدافا مشروعه لقوتها لتبقى
مدينه سيباس عرضه لهجمات اوكرانيه متكرره
بطائرات مسيره في اطار ما يراه خبراء
تغييرا في استراتيجيه اوكرانيا في هجومها
المضاد باعتماد ضربات تستهدف منشات
استراتيجيه وحيويه وتخترق العمق الروسيه
وتصل للعاصمه موسكو بدلا من الهجوم البري
الواسع وفي هذا الاطار نشرت هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه صورا
قالت انها تظهر تدريب القوات الخاصه
البريطانيه قرابه الف جندي من مشاه
البحريه الاوكرانيه على القيام بعمليات
برمائيه على متن قوارب صغيره
[موسيقى]